here's how to raise your prices without
pissing anyone off the way to make any
change whether it's price or
programmatic is actually to appeal to a
higher ideal you will always have The
High Ground in any discussion if you go
off morality and so what that means is
if I say hey I made you this promise
that I wanted to fulfill I want to help
you achieve this thing I have the moral
duty to help you do that I no longer
feel like the services that we have can
help it now that I know what I know now
because I am a growing entrepreneur and
I've learned more things these are the
things that I have to do in order to
fill my original promise and part of
that means it's going to cost more and
that's okay because for me my Integrity
is number one and that is what I'm going
to maintain so as a result of this
change in price these are all the
additional things you're going to get
it's going to happen faster it's going
to happen easier for you and all of
these because I have to stay true to my
promise and that's what I'm going to do
and so when you make it that way no one
can question you because they're like
why don't you raise your price you're
asking me to question my Integrity you
have The High Ground no one can counter
you there and that's how you make those
kind of big problematic changes that
you're afraid of making